[Music]
melissa is in nashville hi Melissa
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show speak
with you you too what's up well my
husband is a he's an orthopedic surgeon
and he's a wiring [ __ ]
he's one of an orthopedic surgeon okay
uh-huh we've been married for 15 years
and we have five kids so kind of
thoughts all of his schooling together
and we had probably the worst case of
DOC eiders I have ever heard anybody
describe on yourself
Wow it was pretty bad but a few months
ago I read the total money makeover and
I read most of your complete guide to
money and I listened to your podcast for
several hours every day and we are ready
to tortoise ready to really attack all
of our debt my question for you is
though my husband though he is in
complete support of doing this he he's
not he does not want to play an active
role in it per se he just says I trust
you I want you to do the budget and I
want you to do everything basically I
don't feel like I'm doing it alone but I
feel like I'm doing it by myself if that
makes sense he does not like to talk
about money I'm sorry I'm just I'm for
him to grow up if he came in and said
kid I really like having kids but I want
you to take care of them you bust his
chops yes and he's not like that he
that's not using that as an example yeah
handling money for this family he can't
he does not have the right to dump them
all the weight of all the
decision-making and all the problems on
your shoulders and walk away and go do
surgery sorry Bubba you got a man up
okay so my son do I push in the causes
and what should cause tension you should
not it's it's a marital
it's not a financial question you should
not be asked to shoulder this all by
yourself now I do not want him to do the
budget I do not want him to write the
checks but I want him to look at the
budget with you yeah for at least 30
minutes a week while you guys would make
the end then you and then you'd make the
decisions for this household together
and he sees the weight and the stress
associated with this and he carries it
with you I don't like to talk about
money oh I'm sorry it's time to be a
grown-up okay and now he doesn't have to
do it all you can be the nerd you can be
the executor
you know the administrative person that
does everything but it's not fair to you
to carry all this by yourself
and you have all this time so I'm glad
he's supportive of your new cute
direction wink nod nope get over there
and helper sir it's your job you don't
have to do everything she's gonna do the
hard work but you make the decisions
together
lay the plan out together once a week
and then you personally execute it